[Music]
it seems like a lot of care goes into
making sure that the math and science
behind what you guys are talking about
is real and I heard that that actually
someone watching your show was inspired
to have an idea about compressing
information if it might lead to a real
patent is that right maybe I don't know
the story that I got told was that
someone sort of freeze-framed anytime
there was a whiteboard of math or
anything any type of equation they took
all those equations out and made it into
a compression code it didn't work very
well because sadly if we had invented
groundbreaking compression our show
would be worth a lot more
it would IPO the term you wouldn't be
doing the show now you all just walk
away and be billionaires yeah I don't
know it's like on Big Bang they go to
great lengths to make sure that the math
that's on the board is actually real
math yeah we had a Stanford professor
check out the elihss the plausibility of
I don't know at the end of season one
the whole d2f which these are words I
can't say doing you know if you've got a
guy here and a guy there and you do you
watch the show
okay so they're like they're tough yeah
yeah they just think you're skiing
that's all good I'm skiing yeah they had
a Stanford professor make sure that that
math was right why aren't people working
on real wage why is it why Stanford
professor doing that I mean he was
probably like I've almost got to cure
for cancer
hold on Silicon Valley got Eric off code
got answer an email from Hollywood well
I think it's great me personally I'm a
bit nerdy and when I see things
represented in film and television that
feels inaccurate I get little I get mad
I get a little mad and I think this show
wants to cradle us weird angry nerds who
have access to the Internet so we don't
go on Twitter and be like actually it
would take way longer to jerk off all
those guys in the room it's a bit it's
we want the show to be like a FUBU for
nerds or us by us you are so committed
to your character you're so good at
playing your character you've had the
issue of people confusing you with your
character is that true you've had people
come up to you and say I've got an idea
that I'd like to pitch you because I
know that you could get at some traction
with all my connections yeah welcome Val
and not realizing they know that's how I
roll I'm playing the crate the weirdest
thing I've been pitched was a new
ergonomic
breast pump which when he pitched it to
me I'm like I like the sound of it yeah
like who puts you that a guy was in the
breast pump game and his whole line you
in I'm in the breast pump game see is my
car
yeah he he pitched it it's like yeah of
course what wouldn't want what woman
wouldn't want a quiet non you know
obtrusive cute little shoulder carrying
breast pump but then at the same time I
said Thomas you don't know a thing about
breast pumps pump the brakes yeah on the
breast yeah but uh yeah and it's weirdly
enough it turns out I mean I don't know
where I'm going with this
I actually know someone through my
through my marriage I know someone in
the breast pump game I know like the guy
who is like the main distributor of
breast pumps I have suddenly been sucked
into a world of restaurants and I'm
unintentionally using words within the
breast pump world
I've been sucked into the world of
breast pumps right
you're undulating with ideas yes and I
hope to be lactating with money
you